this is Peter Roberts I oversee the
Americas for jill's lang lasalle and I
just came from a most interesting
session on the future of Europe and I
will tell you if there was one consensus
the consensus was frustration that we
haven't figured out the problem yet is
it a problem of lack of competitiveness
is a problem of lack of growth is it a
problem of too much propagate government
spending there were clearly debates all
around those areas but the clear
conclusions were number one Europe will
continue through and in a word muddle
through number two that it will take
leadership that focuses more on acting
regionally as well as speaking
regionally and now I think people think
government leaders are acting or
speaking regionally and acting
nationally and that's hindering the
recovery and that will a combination of
increasing focus on focus on
competitiveness and leadership that
focuses regional instead of nationally
that Europe will continue to muddle
through and come through the last bit of
it is focusing very much on how Europe
takes advantage of the growth engine
that is the Far East